[Music]
fifa 21 is here and it brings plenty of
changes for fans of the series long
neglected career mode
great news for anyone like me who isn't
keen on constantly getting pasted by a
12 year old supercharged and bappe
on ultimate team if like me you're more
keen on negotiating clever transfers
developing the next youth star or
leading the mighty morkum to champions
league glory
here are five big changes to this year's
career mode
and how much of a difference they
actually make
first up transfers have received an
overhaul with the now commonplace
loan to buy arrangement finally an
option and the differences are
immediately apparent when you start a
new career
the game now lets you choose between
strict and loose rules for transfer
negotiations
loose largely seems to be unchanged from
previous editions of the game
but strict adds a new set of rules for
the game's transfer market
with the aim of adding realism and could
make it a bit more difficult to get the
stars into your team
one of the more interesting effects is
that players will no longer move between
rival teams
with clubs being completely apathetic
towards accepting
any kind of interest in their players
from their direct competition
meaning you won't see salah popping up
at manchester city or kane moving to
arsenal
similarly players can according to the
developers at least
hold grudges against certain clubs so
you'd better think twice about
repeatedly clattering neymar
if you're hoping to sign him later down
the line plus if a player has the one
club player trait they'll be inclined to
stick around although the only player i
could find with that trait was
well leo messi might want to update the
old database there ea
as someone who always tries to aim for
realistic transfers in career mode this
is all a welcome
addition although it's not without some
odd wrinkles
bournemouth wouldn't even pick up the
phone when i was playing as southampton
i mean i guess they're rivals but their
boiling hatred for me didn't stop them
coming cap in hand to try and loan my
fourth choice striker
pathetic another big change is the
addition of more developed
training schedules for your squad
allowing you to mark individual days in
the calendar as training
recovery or rest days the training
exercises themselves will be familiar to
long-term fans albeit with the option to
train multiple players at once
with more difficult exercises offering a
higher potential benefit
but a higher penalty to a player's
fitness as with previous training
systems
you can simulate the sessions rather
than play them yourself but every time i
try to do this
each player got a d grade presumably for
don't be so lazy but once you've played
it at least once it defaults to your
highest achieved grade
from that point onwards either way it's
hard to imagine i'll still be interested
in doing the same old training exercises
once i'm six seasons in
by default the training works around
your team's schedule offering a balance
of training rest and recovery days
to ensure your players don't burn out
before big matches but to test how much
of a difference this really made
i decided to take a team full of
over-paid pre-madonas
many are available and put them through
my patented grind their bones into dust
training regime two full weeks of drills
with no rest
or recovery days whatsoever the change
in schedule did in fact have quite a
significant impact
as my exhausted team sad faces all round
shipped seven goals and just about as
many injuries in their first two matches
but honestly if raheem sterling isn't
interested in running up and down the
right wing until his hamstrings
literally explode does he even deserve a
place in my team
he simply must not want it enough
the rejig training system also ties into
the new match
sharpness modifier which indicates how
ready a player is to perform in any
given match as a number out of 100
anything above 50 will give the player a
boost in certain key attributes
and anything below 50 will see a
reduction in attributes in turn
adding a nice risk reward dynamic that
could make all the difference when it
comes to a big match
this creates a pretty interesting
balancing act and could lead to some
tough decisions when it comes to picking
your team do you stick with a rusty
stalwart or swap them out for a younger
player who's raring to go
oh dear still it should add some much
needed variety to your lineups as the
season progresses
perhaps the most exciting addition is
the surprisingly thorough player
development system which gives you many
more opportunities to develop and
specialize your squad
each player can now be assigned a custom
development plan which redistributes
their xp towards certain focused
attributes with a surprising amount of
possibilities
maybe your style of play focuses on
aerial bombardment
why not develop your favorite striker
into a target man
want your hulking seven foot central
midfielder to stay back and shield your
defense
funnel his xp into defensive attributes
you can even go as far as retraining a
player to play in a completely different
position
giving the opportunity to make the most
of trent alexander arnold's absurd
crossing abilities by transforming him
into a right midfielder for example
there doesn't seem to be any limit on
what you can ask your players to
trainers but obviously how long it takes
and how successful it will be is
determined by their stats and their age
with younger players being much easier
to convert to your desired position
meaning you can take that promising
youth team striker and develop him into
an all-action poacher like
southampton's danny ings or a pacey
complete forward like
southampton's danny ings
[Applause]
i love danny ings ah yes
simulation because after you've spent
hours carefully cultivating your squad
honing your training regime and
developing the next youth team sensation
what better way to celebrate than by
letting the ai take over
and play the game for you honestly
having a football manager style
simulation is not something that i ever
really wanted from fifa
but it's certainly a nice option to have
particularly for those money-making
friendlies
and the early round cup games plus if
you're a real glory hunter you can wait
until your player is clean through on
goal
and then jump into the match and take
control
that was all me that goal however
there's one very specific thing i hate
about the new simulation option
and that's the fact that they've put it
where team management used to be on the
bloody match menu
meaning i've had to unlearn years of
muscle memory to stop myself from
accidentally starting the match before
i've had a chance to tweet my lineup
nightmare it's very easy to be cynical
about
fifa ea's flagship sports title has long
been fairly criticized
for ignoring basically every mode that
isn't the money spinning ultimate team
but for once it feels like career mode
has been given some much needed
attention
it may be a few bells and whistles
rather than the ground up redevelopment
some
fans are after but it might be just
enough to hold your attention
for another season particularly with the
10 hour ea play trial soon being
packaged in with
xbox game pass ultimate in a year where
fifa
overall feels more like a cross gen hold
over than ever
it's nice to see that for career mode at
least it's
headed in the right direction oh oh did
you see that
what a header get off the bar oh you'd
love to see it
[Music]
you